you mentioned briefly that finding
production for an independent film is
harder these days hasn't always been
difficult it absolutely has always been
difficult it's never been easy but
what's happened is it's an already
difficult task has become more difficult
because because to really engage
investors and businessmen and business
women you actually have to make the
whole the whole venture make business
sense now there they're always gonna be
some investors that that have
discretionary disposable income that you
know can just believe in your project
and and dump money into it whether or
not they they get a they get a return or
not there's always going to be that
marginal group that you know hey you put
my granddaughter in your movie then yeah
I'll I'll put $100,000 in sure you know
and or they just like believe in the
purpose your project and they'll dump it
in that that is a rarity and what we
have to do is we have to approach the
business of filmmaking from a
perspective of an investor and learn
what motivates an investor learn the
value propositions behind the business
model so that they can feel comfortable
with with giving you their you know
their money that they've worked very
hard on or hard for and you now once
they give you your money you as a
filmmaker have what the quote I'll give
you a law school term is it's called a
fiduciary responsibility you have a
fiduciary responsibility which is a
legal and ethical responsibility to be
able to take care of that money take
care of the investment and do everything
that you can to get a return on that
investment and and so it's it's not a I
never take anybody that gives me money
lightly at all it's it's it's one of the
highest compliments and one of the
biggest responsibilities that you have
as a filmmaker and so now you have to
you have in order to get that you have
to have the whole thing make business
sense so you have to imagine what what
motivates an investor it's it's probably
not your three-act structure it's
probably not your really amazing be
story plot it's not your your
interesting subplots it's not your plot
twist in your act three it's how do you
get them a return on investment it's
it's the amount of ROI the return on
investment it's how long is this gonna
be in the marketplace is this short term
investment or is there is it a long term
investment
it's how big is the market that you're
trying to attack is it you know very
small or is it very large there's the
there's these things that we're trying
to that we have to try to figure out
filmmakers hate this stuff because
they're creatives right that's why
usually filmmakers need good you know
directors and writers need good
producers because producers can think
this way but what from my perspective is
if a creator if a if the writers and the
directors if you can be thinking this
way from the beginning then and approach
the creative decisions that you make in
your in your story in such a way that
optimizes your IP your script your
project for larger investment and larger
revenue potential all of a sudden that's
the best because you're not just leaving
it to the quote-unquote bean-counters to
figure out you're not leaving it to a
producer to sell the investment the
creative is optimized for the for the
investment for example going back to the
the the the the principles of George
George Lucas Darth Vader this the scene
in the Empire Strikes Back where Darth
Vader's talking to the bounty hunters
could have been between Darth Vader and
Boba Fett there didn't have to be any
other characters they're just Darth
Vader saying Boba Fett go catch Han Solo
but Lucas made the creative decision in
the story to have Boba Fett and eight
other bounty hunters there in that scene
now what that did that creative decision
then spurred a whole other product that
was part of the business
plan which was this anthology of short
stories that existed in the marketplace
to engage the fan base and generate
revenue that all was was promised and
created and birthed out of the creative
decision of the writer and director to
have multiple characters in the scene so
so a lot of a lot of times there's been
this divide this this thinking that
there's a divide between the creative
and the business but if the creative can
understand the business and create in a
way that optimizes it optimizes the
project for the business then there's so
much more opportunity out there because
if it's not built right creatively then
that will maximize or limit the type of
business opportunities that you have
down the road and so so if you can just
build the project right present it right
to a to an investor and it makes
business sense yeah I was talking to an
investor in Canada recently who yeah I I
were part of a project and and I call
him he's this big-time angel investor
has ten thousand angel investors
underneath him and his network of angel
investors guys a big guy and I got on
the phone with him he said hey Houston
I'm gonna give you I'm gonna give you
ten minutes and I said okay he said I
charge $10,000 an hour for my business
consultation I I don't speak anywhere
for less than $25,000 you know per event
and it's not fair to all those people
that pay all that money that I give you
a bunch of free time but because we had
a little bit of relationship because we
spoke at this a similar event you have a
few years prior he said I'll give you
ten minutes free and I said okay he's
the guy who's like straight business guy
right he I said well I want here to talk
to you about this film project that we
have going on and he stopped me 90
seconds and he said listen he said out
of my 10,000 angel investors I could
probably only think of four who would
even consider investing into
entertainment at all and he said it's
just too risky
he said you proud if you get a return
you're gonna give
turn for about a year and a half after
its release it's just it's a difficult
market and the difficult invested
investment to make but maybe there's
four and if everything goes well you may
be able to get a one hundred fifty one
hundred thousand dollars out of each of
them so you know we're looking at a you
know 200,000 children $50 dollar
investment if all goes really super well
and I said well I appreciate that but
really what we want to do is this isn't
just going to be a film project this is
going to be what we call a super story
it's going to be at this large-scale
transmedia project that's going to have
you know all these different things as a
part of it and I sat there and talked to
him one for 90 minutes and and I'm start
talking about the different revenue
opportunities the different markets that
we're going to touch the different the
shelf life of the project how we're
gonna build pre awareness while the
movies going to be being produced how
we're gonna take some things that would
we're gonna shift some things in the
advertising budget to more content story
stuff that we can release simultaneous
to the film so wouldn't extend the
experience then we're gonna release
other things after the film that's gonna
bridge the gap to the next film and he
said he said to me he said in 30 years
of investment no one's ever approached
me with an entertainment pitch that is
that has sounded like this he said this
sounds like a franchisable business more
so than it does a movie
he said based on this I think we could
do two rounds of financing I think we
could do a 75 million dollar round of
financing and a second round of 50
million dollars I could probably give
you access to 4,000 of my angels and he
said because now it makes business sense
and and I didn't even get in to talk to
him about the creative this guy doesn't
care about my characters he doesn't care
about the the story he cares about the
model of it
and but the the creative decisions were
the things that created those
opportunities for those other products
and other things so it goes it works
together so you can never really
separate it and so it you know that just
shows you and like the other example
that the guy that going out after the
$10,000
investment getting in 231 thousand
dollar investment that's the other end
of the spectrum but the result is very
similar one thing does it make business
sense but when you can now create a
project that makes business sense now it
everything makes much more sense and
what it does it hedges the investment it
makes the investment more secure because
all investors are risk-averse they they
don't want to just throw their money
away and so if you can make them more
comfortable with the fact that the the
investment is secure now they said ok
this is you know I'm part of this for
the long term there's here there's
opportunity here here here and here
now it just makes a lot more sense for
them and you know and then you incur
it's still difficult don't get me wrong
it's still difficult but you just
increase the chances for success and
also separate yourself the marketplace
and so you know Tim Kring the guy that
created Heroes he just got a 50 million
dollar investment into a transmedia
company that he started with another guy
here in town called Zach Kass and they
they created a whole transmedia company
and they went to an oilman in Texas and
this woman said I've never invested in
entertainment ever in my whole life but
when they approached me with this
transmedia model it made business sense
and so and so he you know dumped 50
million dollars into their venture and
so what it what it does is is it gives
you access to to a different type of
investment and more investors when you
can really understand how how markets
work how we can get more audience how we
can get different types of audience how
you know how we can diversify income
excetera etc etc all this sounds very
uncreated right I mean you know I can
see like screenwriters watching this
video probably cringing right now but
what was really interesting is is none
of these other opportunities of the
tie-ins or the spin offs or the other
products that you can that you can
surround your project with that those
won't be possible or at least possible
in a good way if you don't create the
story to be able to optimize it for that
go back to that Lucas example he made
the creative decisions
to have eight characters in a scene
rather than to that then fueled hundreds
of thousands of dollars worth of revenue
and an engagement opportunity for the
fanbase so so the story drives the
business
you